(cheerful upbeat music)
- [Kelly] You look so cute.
- I get dressed up for you.
- I'm just saying you look so cute.
Y'all look like you're going
to the best party ever.
Both of you.
- This is the party.
- Welcome to the party.
(audience cheering)
Have y'all ever met before?
- We haven't.
- No, we haven't.
- I don't believe we have, but
I'm very aware of your work.
- [Colin] I'm very aware of your work.
- Chuffed to be next to you.
(audience laughing)
- All right. You must
love Agatha Christie?
This is your second one, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it is.
- [Kelly] I literally
never read her books.
I didn't really know much about her.
And I read one and then I got
obsessed and I read so many.
- Yeah, it's a safer territory
because they're so well written.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. The
storytelling is impeccable.
- Yeah, and the characters are always
so whip smart and intelligent and, yeah.
- Especially a woman killing it
at the time she was killing
it, you know what I'm saying?
Or literally killing it.
Everyone dies. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
Wrong word usage. (laughs)
Did you watch a lot of American shows
when growing up in London?
- [Lucy] Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] What was one of your favorites?
- God, a lot of them.
"The OC" was a good one.
- [Kelly] "The OC"?
Weren't you on "The OC"?
(audience applauding)
- I was, I was.
- [Lucy] I'm sorry.
- No, it's okay.
I made a movie called "Orange County"
and then I was on one
episode of "The OC," yes.
- You're really into
Orange County. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
You're really into "The OC."
I like it, I like it.
I love that she's like, "I'm
gonna casually drop that."
(Colin and Lucy laughing)
Other than that, "Sabrina the
Teenage Witch" was a big one.
The movie, "My Girl" was
probably the reason why I'm...
- That's how I know the song "Smile."
(audience applauding)
The mom sang it. And
he's allergic to bees.
And he can't see without
his glasses, he kept saying,
oh my God.
- That scene.
And also watching that
girl who was, I think,
10 at the time and I was watching it.
So seeing that emotional
range and be that capable
at that age was, I think, the insight into
maybe you can do this this young.
So I used to watch that
scene, the bee scene,
go out to the bathroom mirror,
and act through the scene.
And be like...
(audience laughing)
- See, that's what I did with music.
I would watch an award show
and I'd see someone sing
and I'd be like, "Okay, okay."
And I'd go to my room and
then hair brush it up.
And I'd kill it. I killed
it of my teddy bears.
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughing)
So you are in love with Paul McCartney.
Is that right? In school?
I mean a lot of people have
been, but have you met him?
- Oh, to this day I'm in love with him.
- [Kelly] He has no idea.
- I can't believe I keep
admitting this on television.
- Whatever.
(audience laughing)
Whatever! Who doesn't love Paul McCartney?
(audience cheering)
I'm just saying.
It's Paul McCartney.
That's a good one. That's a solid crush.
Have you ever met?
- I've been in the same room as him.
(Kelly laughing)
- I love that that's... (laughs)
- And other people that I
was with was meeting him
and I couldn't be yet another
person who goes up to him
and tells him what the
Beatles mean to them and him.
- [Kelly] I hate that feeling.
- I couldn't, so I just
saw him across the room
and gave him a nod and
then he gave me a head dip
and that's all I needed.
(audience laughing)
- You had a head nod exchange.
- That's almost better.
- I felt it was more intimate.
- That's better. That's
the wink and the nod.
That means you're in the club.
(audience laughing)
- I think so. Even if he doesn't
know that I'm in the club.
- You literally invited him
to the club and now it's...
- And now it's me and Paul.
- Exactly.
And this intimate head nod exchange.
(audience laughing)
Did you have anyone like that growing up?
- Yeah, I'm sure I did.
- [Kelly] You don't remember?
- I don't really remember.
- [Kelly] You don't wanna say it!
- [Colin] I don't wanna say.
- You don't wanna say it! (laughs)
- I don't wanna say it.
- I'll say mine.
I had several that I thought were cute,
but I love Steven Tyler.
That "caw caw caw caw," I
was really into all that.
(audience laughing)
And the fan and the way
the hair, he was crazy.
- [Lucy] That's what got you?
- Yeah, and the music. I was
real hardcore into that music.
- Can I get the "caw caw
caw caw" one more time?
- Oh my God, he did it
one time we did a shoot.
It was like peak artists
and then their idols,
people they love and they
knew I loved Steven Tyler,
so they were like, "Will
you do this shoot?"
And then I'm like, "Yes."
And I hate photo shoots,
so when I say yes,
I really wanna be there.
(audience laughing)
And I showed up but it was
so funny 'cause he is very,
he's so cool, but he's very
into, and he was right,
I mean, all my dreams came
true, right up on my face
just like, "ya caw caw caw kow!"
(audience laughing and clapping)
In the photo shoot, full
on on my face. And I froze.
I tried to be cool, but I
froze. I had no cool once again.
(audience laughing)
- You can't.
You can't be cool in that moment.
- I'm never cool in any moment, Lucy.
(audience laughing)
- While doing the head nod
I'm also scarlet at that time.
- Just totally red. I'm not cool.
So your new show is called
"Why Didn't They Ask Evans?"
And those were also the
dying words of the character?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I need to show you this.
We found the cover of this.
This is the first edition of this book
and I need you to see.
(audience laughing)
- [Lucy] That's just the dead guy.
- I know, but that's the
creepiest cover of any,
I just love that someone,
I saw this and I was like,
"Someone was like, 'This is
gonna help this book sell.'"
(audience laughing)
That creeped me out.
- [Lucy] They nailed it.
- Do you even want that guy
in your house? He scares me.
I'm still thinking about it.
(Colin laughing)
I'm just saying. So
tell me about the show.
Other than the cover. (laughs)
- At least it's an impactful
gift. It resonates.
- It did, it stuck with me,
didn't it? I'm terrified.
- Our cover is slightly less traumatizing.
- [Kelly] Thank you for that. (laughs)
- Your welcome.
So it follows Bobby Jones,
played by Will Poulter,
and he stumbles across a dying man
who utters his last words,
"Why didn't they ask Evans?"
And then meanwhile, my character Frankie
rolls back into town and cajoles him to go
on this adventure to get to
the bottom of this mystery.
And it's adapted and
directed by Hugh Laurie.
So to add his comedic timing to that,
it was such a privilege.
It was such a fun one.
- That's so cool.